that time the british people
have made heart-wrenching sacrifices
people were left desperately lonely
they were separated from family and
friends tragically
many were unable to see dying loved ones
this was a collective sacrifice
people were entitled to expect
that politicians would follow the same
rules as everyone else
when my mother-in-law passed away
suddenly just before the lockdown
my wife and i were unable to provide her
father with the support we wanted to
afterwards
because we followed the rules
barely a day has passed where we haven't
agonized over that decision
but we did it
because we followed the rules
we all found the rules frustrating at
times
and i'm no exception to that
i had to isolate six times during covid
pulling me away from my work
and the things that i love
but i did it
because we followed the rules
the idea
that i would then
casually break those rules is wrong
and frankly i don't believe those
accusing me believe it themselves
they are just trying to feed cynicism
to get the public to believe all
politicians are the same
i'm here to say that they're not
i believe in honor
integrity
and the principle
that those who make the laws
must follow them
and i believe that politicians who
undermine that principle
undermine trust in politics
undermine our democracy
and undermine britain
i'm absolutely clear that no laws were
broken
they were followed at all times
i simply had something to eat while
working late in the evening
as any politician would do
days before an election
but if the police decide to issue me
with a fixed penalty notice
i would of course
do the right thing
and step down
this matters
it matters
because the british public deserve
politicians
who think the rules apply to them
they deserve politicians who hold
themselves to the highest standards
and they deserve politicians who put the
country first
rather than themselves
they will always
always
get that from me
thank you
i'll now take questions i think
beth we've agreed you'll go first yes
um
when it was announced on friday that you
were going to be investigated by the
police it was pretty clear to everyone
that should you be issued a fixed
penalty notice or even actually you
haven't said this but be found in breach
of lockdown regulations that given what
you've said about the prime minister
you'd have no option but to resign so
what my first question is why did it
take you so long to arrive at that
position is it because you're aware of
the huge gamble that you're taking and
you were frightened by that
beth no rules were broken i've been
absolutely clear about that from start
to finish
and
i've set out today the in-principle
position that i believe in unlike those
at downing street i don't think those
that make the laws can then simply
breach them
and not uh take action i believe that if
you've made a law you should respect the
law and if you're found to be in breach
of it you should step down and that's
what i've set out clearly this afternoon
it's a gamble for you though
beth this is a matter of principle and
honour for me it's about who i am what i
stand for and i stand for honor and
integrity
on the belief that uh politics is a
force for good and we shouldn't all be
dragged down by this cynical belief that
all politicians are the same and i'm
here to make it clear that i am not the
same we've seen 50 finds in downing
street we've seen a prime minister won't
step down we are not all the same i am
different and i've set out today how i'm
different
i just want one more and then i promise
our hand over on january the 31st you
put out a tweet you said honesty and
decency matter after months of denial
the prime minister is now under criminal
investigation for breaking his own
lockdown laws he needs to do the decent
thing and resign so you said then that
the prime minister should resign because
he was under criminal investigation
which you now are as well
isn't it rather hypocritical
that you said that of him but you're not
prepared to resign right now what what
do you say to people that say you're a
hypocrite
i've set out my position very clearly
i've taken a very different course to
the prime minister of course um did
break the laws and then didn't resign
i'm setting out a very different course
i have different principles to the prime
minister and i think it's very important
the public see that not all politicians
are the same i'm very different to the
prime minister in this regard in terms
of the principle the honor and the
integrity of the office that i hold